I I really don't like liberals liberals
really like to announce these liberal
audiences liberal audiences these are my
gays
yeah they're your props I'm sure they
really appreciate that friends do you
know anything about them or is it just
that they're gay they they enhance your
your eclectic group of friends liberals
will use ethnic groups as props in their
pictures it's a little weird no gay
pride month is more about straight
people to show how many gay friends they
have than it's actually about gay people
like how many of those things you see of
like white women showing up to the black
lives matter March and like taking a
picture and then just leaving
I was like that's not supposed to be for
your social that's supposed to be a
thing there should have been no selfies
like that a race is a good deed you're
now you're showing like I'm a great
person you're using their misery is that
the liberal version of standing in your
background with a yes machine gun like
holding up the dead animal that is kind
of what it is you're using them they're
you're dead you're treating them like a
dead animal